bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous venez
de nous rejoindre sur téléphiles pour le
7-8 une heure pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale il sera question
d'économie d'emploi au cours de la
première partie de cette édition du 17
janvier bonsoir alice elle la chronique
de l'écho qui va se pencher sur
notamment la réforme du marché du
travail
oui les négociations sont maintenant
terminées entre représentants du
patronat et des salariés le gouvernement
vont maintenant devoir présenter son
projet de loi à l'assemblée avec nous
sur ce plateau bertrand de craie bonsoir
vous êtes présidente du medef dans les
yvelines à vos côtés melchior palacio
secrétaire général de la cfdt dans les
yvelines
et puis est toujours en économie le
responsable marketing d'asmodée un cette
société éditrice de jeux de société
installée à guyancourt inquiétant en
plein développement viendra sur ce
plateau prochains développements
d'ailleurs la chine
on parlera de ce marché des perspectives
pour cette entreprise yvelinoise
économies dans quelques minutes pour
l'instant voici les titres en images les
autres sujets quelques uns des autres
sujets que nous allons développer ce
soir à la mobilisation des salariés du
technocentre renault à guyancourt comme
tous les jeudis un point hebdomadaire
d'information et effet le syndicat sud
envisage un appel à la grève après les
annonces d'hier est de la direction sur
les suppressions de postes le plan grand
froid niveau 2 déclenché dans le
département le 115 le numéro du samu
social a reçu 276 appel dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi et nous ferons le point
sur le dispositif avec la directrice
adjointe de la cohésion sociale
une halte répit pour les malades
d'alzheimer va ouvrir ce samedi à
maurepas la voici en images elle nous
avons rencontré les bénévoles lors de
leur dernière réunion d'organisation une
halte répit mise en place par la croix
rouge
et puis tout autre univers un spectacle
tout en poésie et en imaginaire proposé
ce vendredi et ce samedi à la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux la
vie
onze des moutons en islande vous avez
bien entendu c'est surprenant et c'est à
découvrir au cours de cette édition
le deuxième niveau donc du plan grand
froid qui a été à déclencher les mesures
prioritaires et surtout que faire si
vous voyez dans la rue une personne sans
domicile fixe en difficulté les
explications katerine the nato elodie
moines centre d'hébergement des
mortemets à versailles ce midi ce centre
fait partie du dispositif pérenne ouvert
toute l'année dans le département
émile 118 places d'urgence proposées
mais en période hivernale 3 149 places
se rajoutent et le plan de prévention
est renforcée selon la température
depuis ce jeudi le département est passé
en niveau 2 sur trois possibles ce qui
implique un renforcement des outils
il implique une augmentation des places
qui sont donc ouvertes
il implique un renforcement des maraudes
pour à la fois la croix-rouge le l'ordre
du mat et les maraudes communal il
implique une ouverture plus grande des
abris de jours on envoie plusieurs mails
successifs dans les journées comme
celle-ci pour faire le tour de toutes
les structures et on va jusqu'à ouvrir
des places assises si jamais vraiment y
avait un manque de places en lice ce
niveau 2 sera maintenue jusqu'à mardi
matin
le 115 le numéro d'appel d'urgence est
lui très sollicité dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi le service a reçu 276
appel et nouveauté depuis une semaine
tous les appels sont vérifiées même ceux
qui n'aboutissent pas et toutes les
personnes recontacter
c'est ce que le 115 a fait hier soir
jusqu'à 23h30 hier c'était pour la
première fois depuis la période
hivernale s'est étendue et les appels
ont été tardifs
c'est à dire en fait à partir de 19
heures quand les gens commençaient à
sentir vraiment le froid intense le 115
peut dans ce cas faire le choix d'ouvrir
des places d'hébergement dans les hôtels
le département connaît l'arrivée d'un
nouveau type de population des habitants
de la petite couronne parisienne est de
plus en plus de familles avec enfants
la chronique de l'écho qui débute donc
ce soir par un point sur cette réforme
du marché du travail au terme de trois
mois de laborieuses négociations
syndicats et patronat ont conclu un
accord sur la sécurisation de l'emploi
françois hollande le président qui
évoque un succès du dialogue social
projet de loi qui sera présenté en
conseil des ministres en mars
ensuite examiné par l'assemblée en avril
et promulgation prévue fin mai ce soir
nous allons revenir sur les principaux
points les grandes lignes de cet accord
avec le medef est donc la cfdt
on attend vos réactions sur sur ces
accords est ce que vous êtes satisfait
l'un et l'autre à temps à créer
j'écoutais moi je vais reprendre les
mots de laurence parisot très rapidement
cet accord marque l'avènement d'une
culture de compromis après après des
décennies de d'une philosophie
d'antagonistes sociale donc ça c'est à
des points très positifs de cet accord
qui va peut-être en or c'est en amorçant
un progrès nous permettent de regagner
de la compétitivité
qu'est-ce que du côté de la cfdt
partagez cet avis plutôt oui parce qu'on
va le voir tout à l'heure tous les
syndicats en tout cas ne sont pas
d'accord avec ce qui a été proposé
discuter je dois dire qu'effectivement
l'ex de la cfdt
depuis la conférence sociale et la
demande qu'on avait fait c'était de
s'engager activement sur sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi et les parcours
professionnels
donc ça c'est un axe fdt on a obtenu un
certain nombre de choses donc on est
plutôt satisfait effectivement
effectivement leurs représentants au
niveau national vont signer l'accord
puisque c'est parce qu'en fait ça
permettra de franchir une nouvelle étape
de la sécurisation des parcours
professionnels des salariés de faire
reculer la précarité sur le marché du
travail et d'anticiper les mutations
économiques afin de mieux protéger les
salariés préserver l'emploi la cgt qui
va signer
cet accord vous nous le dites en revance
cgt et force ouvrière ne vont pas signer
l la cgt qui voit je cite une grave
régression des droits sociaux des
salariés force ouvrière part d'un texte
profondément déséquilibré et j'en
profite pour vous signaler que nous
organiserons bien sûr dans les
prochaines semaines lors de l'examen de
ce projet de loi par le gouvernement un
débat sur le plateau l'ensemble des
syndicats elle sera bien évidemment
conviés mais ce soir nous voulions
revenir sur les sur les grandes lignes
ont déjà mais avant de rentrer un petit
peu dans le détail de cet accord
peut-être votre sentiment du côté du
medef vous parliez de laurence parisot
qui soulignait une nouvelle culture de
la négociation visiblement il reste
encore difficile de discuter même si la
cgt force ouvrière sont pas là ce soir
sur ce plateau pour vous répondre mais
qu'elle est en tout cas du côté du medef
votre point de vue c'est que
heureusement que le syndicat comme ce
sont là
ce que pour avancer faut être deux quand
on bloque dans un dogmatisme
d'un autre temps on peut pas arriver à
négocier quelque chose et la cgt qui
parle d une fois de plus d'une grave
régression des droits sociaux des
salariés passent pas tellement examen je
veux dire que quand on quand on voit
aujourd'hui la génération de la
complémentaire santé si pas une avancée
c'est quoi quand on voit que les
contrats courts voix de plus taxer c'est
quoi qu'est ce que c'est que tout ça
enfin les avancées elles sont pas
tendance de blanc ce dossier juste je
passais environnantes
on va s'intéresser aux c'est
complémentaire santé oui tout à fait
c'est un christ est un des points les
plus importants de cette négociation
donc les personnes qui n'en
bénéficiaient pas le seront au plus tard
au 1er janvier 2016 ce sont donc les
différentes branches qui rechercheront
des tarifs les tarifs les plus
intéressants le coût sera partagé à
50/50 avec l'employeur voilà c'était
vraiment un peu important du côté la
cfdt
oui c'était une demande effectivement
c'était une demande des demandes de plus
importante je pense que ça a été celle
aussi où il ya eu le moins de
difficultés à arriver à un accord
donc effectivement c'était très
important je pense que on a besoin de
garder effectivement une couverture
sociale les manquer licenciement
exactement si vous êtes salarié dont
vous pourrez conserver votre couverture
santé et prévoyance pendant un an et non
plus neuf mois comme ça ça fait je
tousse un point où les accords on était
plus difficile pour pour aboutir c'est
la taxation des cdd c'était plutôt un
point qui posait un problème du côté du
medef le goût des cdd jusqu'à 6 mois
sera augmentée par une majoration des
cotisations d'assurance chômage payées
par l'entreprise à la cotisation actuel
c'est 4% pour les cdi pour les cdd ce
sera autour de 7% pour notamment les
contrats inférieurs à un mois 5 5% pour
les contrats entre un et trois mois
voilà le taux est dégressif en fonction
de la durée donc du cdd cette taxation
des cdd pourquoi ça peut poser un
problème véritablement pour les
entreprises parce qu'aujourd'hui s'il ya
eu cette taxation c'est parce que les
entreprises font de plus en plus on leur
appel à des cdd jouer qu'on revienne un
peu le cdd les cdd
je dirais qu'il ya deux types il ya des
cdd qui sont subis et ils sont pas dans
la capitale où a grandi subi une de vos
employés
l'enceinte elle doit avoir un enfant
date prochaine maternité ampli quatre
heures on la remplace on fait un cdd les
saisonniers une entreprise qui côtière
qui voit sa population augmenter de
milliers par dix il fait les aider ce
que j'appelle des dépôts obligatoires y
et ne sont pas taxées il ya des 6es
l'hérault la loire qui ne signent pas
obligatoire et les entreprises et qu'ils
sont faits alors pour les entreprises
qui on peut ajuster leurs flux qui ont
des commandes qui bouge ont besoin
d'avoir une structure
et puis clairement il y as certainement
parce que tout n'est pas rose du côté
entreprises des idées de confort et cela
met alors nous il fallait d'abord
l'achat d'habits nourris au lait dénoncé
le mauvais comportement est toujours
dénonçables si un employeur aujourd'hui
prend des cdd par confort ne sais pas et
ne suis pas une bonne position
maintenant si effectivement il a il a
tout d'un coup une régression de ses
commandes et qui là et que l' équilibre
l'entreprise fait qu'il étudierait
diakité recourir en tant qu'employé
majolan des patrons s'y est pas trompé
mais aujourd'hui moi je n'aime pas en
bourse d'aidé parce qu'ils sont déjà
très taxée
ils sont déjà taxés ils sont en plus et
qu est-ce qu
peut-on nous employeurs nous patrons
c'est avoir des employés formés en cdi
c'est bien plus sécurisant pour la vie
de l'entreprise
on préfère cent fois cela comme il
préfère pas d'un top sur l'avenant mail
il y en a il y en a mais alors est ce
qu'il faut à chaque fois si vous voulez
chemin prendre la minorité qui agit mal
et la majorité qui agit bien c'est aussi
je vois pas de remettre les pendules à
l'heure c'est que le fait de minorités
que je condamne quand ils sont de
confort simplement de confort ils sont
souvent de nécessité nous étions
vraiment d'accord avec oui oui parce que
des contrats d'un mois appartement on a
roulé avec ce que justement ces cdd
remplacement logique et normaux le reste
je suis le plus de règle générale on
parlait d'un point qui bloquait un petit
peu le patronat le medef c'était donc
cette taxation des cdd notre point c'est
l'accord qu'il ya eu finalement malgré
au départ le désaccord des syndicats sur
le maintien de l'emploi
oui oui c'est le grand le grand retour
un désaccord de compétitivité emploi
cher à nicolas sarkozy en cas de graves
difficultés conjoncturelles rencontrées
par une entreprise voilà le texte
prévoit la possibilité de conclure des
accords majoritaires d'entreprise
portant sur le temps de travail et la
rémunération
voilà comment ça s'est passé et
traitements ça veut dire qu'on va
diminuer le temps de travail
on va diminuer le salaire dans les
entreprises ou des difficultés sont
avérés alors c'est pas nouveau c'est ça
existe déjà
moi ce que je dirais c'est que
effectivement là il ya un cadre
on est passé d'une situation un peu
anarchique où chacun pouvait évidemment
le donner négocier et souvent dans
l'entreprise des semblant d'accord laon
le cadre où le cas il ya des années
certaines dispositions qui vont encadrer
ces accords là et on limite dans le
temps
c'est ce genre de situation parce qu'il
veut dire qu'on va pas faire
effectivement d'accord par entreprise et
dire on oublie demain donc ça va être
vraiment tout est cadré ce qui est
intéressant dans ce texte c'est qu'il ya
cadre est effectivement dans le temps et
puis aussi prévoir le retour à une
normalité
une fois que l'entreprise et a repris le
dessus
sa sélection pour le salarié c'est plus
d'information plus de clarté
je pense que notre but premier nous à la
cfdt c'est de conserver l'emploi c'est
c'la point de vue pour l'heure ce qui
nous fait tous même aux salariés que si
l'entreprise est en difficulté ils vont
gagner moins alors avoir une partie de
deux temps de travail réduit
ça va être le effectivement une des
partie de celles qu'on a négocié qu'ont
obtenu c'est à dire la représentativité
dans l'entreprise
comment quel rôle vont jouer les
représentants du personnel quels rôles
vont jouer les syndicats et aussi
comment on va pouvoir être impliqué puis
s'assoit dans les petites entreprises
comme dans les très grosses avec une
possibilité d'entrer au conseil
d'administration a désavoué sa figure
dans les affections avec une voix qui
effectivement sera dé libératrice notre
regard justement sur sept ce recours à
ce temps réduit de travail ces
diminutions de salaire de plus de faux
témoins j'ai oublié de vous dire quelque
chose tout à l'heure les contrats
terminer le plus grand faiseur de
contrat de confort et de contrat c'est
l'état quand même faut pas l'oublier
c'est le public à faut pas oublier que
cette public ce soir on va s'intéresser
à ces simples comme le glisse et ça
c'est important de le savoir car courant
revient sur sa revenir cette sextape
qu'il faut trouver des moyens une autre
prise aujourd'hui si qui n'a qui n'a
plus les moyens de payer ses salariés
parce qu'elle n'a plus de commandes si
on ne trouve pas des abers d'ajustement
elle va couler et si jeudi sur un autre
une autre fois ci elle coule c'est tout
le monde qui coule donc il faut trouver
la mesure juste et c'est là tout l'objet
de la négociation entre classes sociales
il ne faut pas justement que ce soit une
flexibilité d'enrichissement il faut
faire une publicité de sécurité et c'est
dans ce sens là que nous voulons mener
une négociation
effectivement pour le bien de tous si on
maintient bêtement tous les emplois le
seul objectif on peut enfin nationale qu
à quoi il a pincé de couler tout le
monde forcément l'objectif on va
continuer à parler de l'emploi on va
quitter un petit peu le cadre de ces
accords pour se pencher sur un autre
sujet de l'actualité économique c'est la
question du travail le dimanche
oui ils sont concernés en particulier
les magasins de bricolage en pleine
polémique les salariés se mobilisent
pour conserver ce drap ce droit au
travail le dimanche
reportage dans les yvelines les salariés
des principales enseignes de bricolage
mobilisés sur les réseaux sociaux
objectif conserver le droit au travail
dominical est sur le terrain aussi il ne
manque pas l'occasion de faire passer
leurs messages comme ici à bois d'arcy
c'est complètement basé sur le
volontariat on signe tous les ans des
feuilles on met le nombre de dimanches
qu'on souhaite faire ou pas si on n'est
pas volontaire on le met aussi pour dire
qu'on ne le souhaitent pas travailler le
dimanche
à moi ça me gêne absolument battre à et
dimanche étant donné que
je suis en cours toute la semaine du
lundi au vendredi pour moi travailler le
week-end ça me permet de pas du tout
anxiété sur ma semaine de cours dont
tous les jours donc c'est vraiment
parfait et en plus de ça on aurait moins
en conséquence donc pour moi c'est un
bénéfice et c'est nécessaire ça
représente aucun problème ce problème
c'est qu'on soit obligé de se battre
pour pouvoir jouer dimanche
les salariés sont quasi unanimes quant
au fait de travailler le dimanche
les clients aussi sont enthousiastes
même s'il ne semble pas favorable à une
généralisation de l'ouverture dominicale
à l'ensemble des commerces
je suis plutôt contre l'ouverture des
magasins le dimanche mais tant qu'ils
sont ouverts j'y vais mais je
comprendrais très bien que les gens ne
veulent plus travailler le dimanche
c'est tout à fait normal serait ce un
peu plus au cas par cas face avec le
bricolage on fait souvent sale week-end
après les courses 20 points
l'alimentaire par exemple j'ai moins
d'avis là dessus puisque on fait ça la
semaine tant que l'employé s'y retrouve
c'est bien s'il vous voyez ci retrouve
la loi encadre de manière stricte
l'ouverture le dimanche les magasins
doivent être situés dans une zone
touristique où sur un puce un périmètre
d'usagé de consommation exceptionnel
certes un brave les interdits comme
bricorama qui a été assigné en justice
est interdit d'ouvrir le dimanche
enfin le divan faire les zorros été
violée c'est sûr et après la pluie il a
fallu revoir après la restructuration du
magasin afin de combler les pertes suite
à ce verdict bricorama assigné en
justice deux de ses concurrents
leroy merlin et castorama qui sont
ouverts le dimanche alors le travail
dominical un donc d'un côté les salariés
entendaient un micro trottoir un
monsieur qui disait tant que le salarié
il trouve son compte tant mieux et puis
ce patron bricorama qui dit
effectivement qu'il ya un manque à
gagner énorme depuis qu'il n'a plus tu
auras d'ouvrir son magasin
alors vos réactions cfdt
nous on est pas opposée effectivement à
l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche
je pense qu'effectivement on n'est pas
non plus points et est encadrée ça de
façon stricte je pense que ça doit être
au cas par cas comme le disait
personnellement partage et elle doit
tenir compte effectivement du personnel
je pense qu'il faut que ça soit sur la
base du volontariat
et puis il faut que cela soit encadré et
que tout le monde s'y retrouve
je pense que quand le patron dit
qu'elles sont plus gros chiffre
d'affaires c'est dimanche eh ben il faut
qu aussi bien que le le salarié s'y
retrouve et que la compensation elle
soit la hauteur
effectivement de l'investissement du
salarié du côté du medef
l'ouverture dominicale est une vraie
nécessité dans ces commerces maj mon
entreprise est ouverte le dimanche matin
les consommateurs ont nous besoin que
l'on peut faire c'est qu'on ne sait pas
forcément vrai mais j'ai beaucoup de
couples qui sont qui travaille toute la
semaine ils n'ont que le samedi et
dimanche alors que l'osce dont le salir
de mosport donc c'est le dimanche c'est
les corps gelés quoi bien venir chez moi
on a une chance en plus en région
parisienne et c'est ce que je fais
référence qui se passe dans notre
reportage c'est qu'on a beaucoup
d'étudiants beaucoup de gens qui font
leurs études et qui sont ravis de
travailler le dimanche
donc les salariés qui sont en place
elles peuvent se reposer le dimanche et
on emploie des jeunes qui sont tes
étudiants et qui n'ont aucune envie
justement c'est de travailler deux
heures trois heures le dimanche pour
pour continuer leurs études
donc il ya souleymane en quoi dans votre
société actuellement comment vous en
prie combien justement de ce type c'est
principalement des caissiers je vais en
avoir une dizaine douzaine qui sont là
que le dimanche les contrats très très
court en temps partiel mais volontaire
parce que des étudiants ils ont pas ils
travaillent trois heures le dimanche et
je suis d'accord aussi avec monsieur cc
on doit le négocier que les salariés qui
sont non pas étudiants et qui
travaillent le dimanche c'est un accord
négocié avec chacun sur la base de
volontariat ça je confirme parfaitement
ça c'est la vie de l'entreprise n'est
pas justement on est puant on n'est pas
en conflit on est il faut trouver
justement les solutions mais le travail
le dimanche
l'ouverture le dimanche est une
nécessité pour beaucoup de commerces
toujours dans le domaine de l'emploi on
a beaucoup parlé forcément depuis hier
des suppressions de postes du côté de
renault 7500 postes supprimés d'ici 2016
le groupe est en grande difficulté
quel regard vous portez sur cette
situation les difficultés rencontrées
par renault ces annonces de suppressions
de postes même si l'entreprise parle
plutôt de départ dit naturel 5500 ans
environ je ne maîtrise pas très bien ce
dossier là mais enfin quelque part genis
c'est toujours triste on est on à
peugeot qui a de gros soucis renault
j'ai des soucis je vais toujours dit
maya vous aimons mon coeur d'activité
sur les pme les tpe département donc je
n'ai le vision y renoncer aussi pour les
mairies conséquence voilà ils sont tout
à fait droit exactement ce sont les les
contrats de ceux qui dépendent de ces de
ces groupes là mais j'ai pas de leçon à
donner aux dirigeants de renault merci
bertrand de créer présidente du medef
dans le département des yvelines on vous
libère je sais que vous devez partir sur
paris mais clan place au second marie
vernet encore quelques instants avec
nous nous allons partir dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines avec ce
micro-trottoir vos réactions sur ces
suppressions de postes du côté de
renault vos réactions moi
personnellement je suis directement
touchée puisque je te réponds à son
autre sous traitant automobile
donc évidemment on est inquiet les
emplois s'en vont effectivement pourrait
faire autrement puisque c'est les
emplois qui font marcher l'économie en
france quoi on devrait laisser la place
en priorité aux entreprises françaises
surtout telles que renault coptes ou
l'automobile
mais bon avec les avec les malus 2013
il ya ça c'était sûr que le secteur
automobile et soient touchés j'imagine
que la crise contribuent largement par
contre le la course aux profits n'est
pas pas du tout donc j'imagine que le
gouvernement doit quand même se poser de
question de la façon dont ils peuvent
solutionner le problème
j'ai pas de solution par contre puisque
évidemment pour être compétitif
on sera jamais compétitif vis-à-vis des
chinois il faut peut être revoir la
manière dont on gère l'économie en
europe
melchior palacios pour la cfdt une
réaction pour vous donc du côté des
syndicats des salariés
ça illustre une partie des sujets qui
ont traité qui ont été traitées fait
d'un effectivement dans cette
négociation sur la gestion
prévisionnelle il là on voit bien que ce
soit peut jouer que ça soit renault on
n'a pas pris suffisamment de recul pour
examiner la situation avec les salariés
je pense que les salariés ont leur point
de vue ils peuvent l'exprimer et peuvent
apporter des choses pour
qu'effectivement la société évolue au
prend effectivement un moment donné des
situations où c'est trop tard c'est trop
tard et voilà qu on passe à des
licenciements peut jouer là par exemple
cette émission début de cette page
consacrée à l'économie ont parlé de ces
accords entre les syndicats entre le
patronat si ces accords finalement avait
réussi à passer avait eu lieu avant
cette situation rencontrée les
difficultés sont aujourd'hui par renault
on n'en serait pas là aujourd'hui dans
ces difficultés la charge et je pense
que la situation ne date pas de diers
date d'avant-hier décidément les accords
avaient eu lieu avant-hier par exemple
si un moment donné s'il y a deux ans on
a discuté effectivement des problèmes de
peugeot s'il y en eut un choix de
travailler effectivement sur la gestion
prévisionnelle de l'emploi et de la
capacité à réagir de ces grosses
entreprises on n'en serait pas là
aujourd'hui
on peut donc s'attendre à des accords
difficiles les négociations difficiles
dans les négociations de branche
industrie la métallurgie
ça restera difficile dans ces branches
là effectivement parce que il ya des
grands groupes et les grands groupes
sont souvent ceux qui sont le plus en
difficulté merci d'être venu donc sur ce
plateau nous avons évoqué ce soir avec
vous et avec le medef 78 cette réforme
du marché du travail et puis je vous le
disais au début de cette édition nous
organisons dans les prochaines semaines
les débats avec l'ensemble des syndicats
merci à lee sont poursuis la page et éco
pour l'instant avec la société asmodée
qui veut se développer en chine
auparavant le point sur les dernières
avancées qui concerne renault ce matin
il y avait une mobilisation encore une
fois avec les différents syndicats un
reportage d' anthony rech et d'élodie
moines sur place à guyancourt
la nouvelle a eu l'effet d'une bombe
ce mercredi la direction de renault a
annoncé la suppression de 7500 postes
d'ici à 2016 sans licenciement ni
fermeture d'usiné les salariés semblent
découragés et écuries je pense que psa a
commencé hier à et ils occupent leur
usine à aulnay donc je pense que ça
c'est une toute façon c'est une réplique
à faire on va pas je comprends bien les
collègues on va pas continuer à monter
des voitures si on sait que eh ben la fa
les oies ou dans trois mois c'est fini
quoi ça sert à quoi il ya donc une forme
de dégoût des cures monde parce que
c'est bon ils ont vraiment le sentiment
qu'on tape toujours sur les mêmes
et puis la deuxième chose dans quelque
chose qui s'était déjà amorcée avec
affaire de faux espionnage c'est la
perte de confiance totale dans la
direction
un document interne révélé par le
parisien ce jeudi tablerait en réalité
sur 8260 départ cela concernerait 4100
départs naturels dont 2150 via les
retraites et 1950 personnes qui devrait
quitter l'entreprise au titre de la ld m
c'est à dire pour cause de licenciement
démission ou mobilité en 2012 les ventes
de la marque au losange ont diminué de
plus de 21%
selon les syndicats ils étaient près de
300 à s'être rassemblés ce jeudi matin
au sein du technocentre de guyancourt
les mouvements de grève devrait être
organisé dans quelques jours la
prochaine réunion de concertation est
prévue le mardi 22 janvier